fish qui compté les petits beauté on y
va la castaldi son livre je n'ai pas lu
médecins sont fait une idée par contre
travailler avec vous faites ce que vous
voulez tout le monde est beau comment
débat où il fermait les yeux fermés les
yeux et dormait dans cette position
maintenant je vais changer de
personnalité
je vais changer sa personnalité l'accord
s'il vous êtes cyril hanouna et vous
prenez le contrôle du plateau 1 2 3 vous
allez bien vous faire chier qu'est ce
qu'il ya à telle at war vas-y fais ta
chronique lapentti chronique mais a bien
sûr déjà la chronique
et bien cet aprem je sais pas si ça vous
intéresse ou pas non non non je fais
quoi du coup fait votre honig mais
arrêtez tout c'est comme ça non cet
aprem ans est allé dans les rues de
paris demandé au public ce qu'il pensait
de benjamin voulez qu'on fasse un pas
oui madame ah oui benjamin castaldi et
bah oui mais c'est vrai qu'à talent y
aller on enseigne alors il est
originaire il est quoi j'ai pas
d'oreillette théorie les pros voulait
lancer à tort 48
oui on danse on danse et musique faisait
régie
comme ça c'est la mère d'anna
oui
bien
la chronique la chronique on est en
retard la chronique ghazi non mais ça va
on n'est pas chez m'asseoir aller à
l'essai on le laisse faire le court pour
aller alors
et est ce que vous pouvez dire que
messmer et ton spectacle vous l'avez dit
soba messmer messmer mais ce père en
spectacle bientôt sur tf1 vendredi soir
rue star sous hypnose c'est mon émission
préférée
j'adore cette émission franchement même
arthur là dedans je trouve sympathique
c'est une super émission c'est génial
bravo messmer j'adore ce que tu vas
manger oslo 10 mans pour messmer
plus riches les petits contrer les
petits beauté on y va la castaldi son
livre je n'ai pas lu mes façons ça
[Applaudissements]
jo
jamais des banlieues où je suis nyon
elle travaille en gal il combat à mener
le combat le combat allait hausser le
salut ça va oui très bien
il est remonté aux consciences d'aller
vous souvenir de tout dans les moindres
détails et avec le 1e dressez-vous avec
le 2 le sourire montre à votre visage
c'est bien être remonte aussi et avec le
3 complètement libérée de toute
suggestion et je pense qu'on peut
applaudir j ai maintenant messieurs
oui
qu'est-ce que je fais là pris possession
du plateau qui est ici j'ai été bon